Kim Kardashian and Kanye West sell their
bel-air mansion for 17 point eight
million dollars perfect
[Music]
the reality star and her rapper hubby
quietly sold their not-so-subtle abode
with the help of million-dollar listings
Josh Altman and his brother Matt the
couple bought the home which sits on an
acre lot for nine million dollars in
2013 and spent two years renovating it
Altman tells ET quote every inch of that
house was thought out by Kim and Kanye
they were the designers adding it's very
artistic very minimalist it's almost
like walking through a museum
Kim and Kanye repositioned the pool
installed some of the largest glass
windows ever created in the state of
California and expanded the house with a
glam room and a giant closet I mean
hello so who's the lucky buyer
entrepreneur philanthropist and aspiring
singer marina Acton Kim personally gave
marina a tour of the house and she
dished 2et about her encounter with the
Mogul quote it was amazing to see
someone who is so popular he's so down
to earth
[Music]